world there were two wolf brothers
living in their home there with their
Papa wolf they all lived happily
together but one day I just took that
dad away forever so now the brothers
were alone and they had to find a new
home they started a journey through the
great big forest wolf brothers wandered
for days nights learning how to live on
their own for the first time
they slept in the backwoods my creepy
creatures barely ate anything they
eventually found a peaceful orchard and
were able to eat in peace
it's that they didn't know I don't just
try to tie them up but the wolf brothers
managed to escape with the help of a
friendly bear I remember he showed them
how to survive and help them to find a
warm camp for the night
when the Big Bertha discovered if the
little one powered Gary wolf
that's how they found themselves even
further headed to the faraway land there
Bob
we do
to find peace
I know I play as captain spirit on my
place they should leave me alone
to our grandparents
some of the 1st 2016
got the dog
oh you're good
you will love
try with it
that one's too easy
look don't brag it was too heavy for you
a few days ago
[Music]
you must use the Force Youngman
let's try to lift something else not too
heavy though I'm a little tired
mushroom oh yeah let's refer guys in a
with mushroom no don't listen to
mushroom I'm so glad Daniel took this
little girl with us yeah me too I don't
want him to lift mushroom we might hurt
mushroom how about trying out that rock
over there just one more time
we're already tried yesterday and the
day before it's too far I can't reach it
just one more time
Wow I'm so close I can feel it
I don't want him to chew on them I don't
want him to do it on the dog how about
that one what'd you do with the small
rats but not the big ones you can do
this trust me
just relax focus I'll try
do or do not there is no try
[Music]
ah he didn't
whoa-ohh
like a boss
you're getting good at you see that much
that was the biggest rock ever hmm
cool I don't want him to do on the doggy
not ethical what about this one this one
too big yeah it's just way too massive
I didn't want to I think you I think I
have to do on my it's getting late and
cold let's go can you throw me this rock
in the river oh yeah
just watch
- okay let's Joe Daniel some more stuff
to play with before we call it a day
just not mushroom
how about those cans can you fly them
all together without dropping any sure
look
that's the band that's awesome dude
you're getting way better at this come
on dude that's just the start
let's try something else cool
you're like co-chairing you're my power
a snowball fight
not yet this is the new exercise young
apprentice see if you can stop this in a
year
cool okay well you better not hit me
like that time you gave me a bruise
serious you won't let me right try it
[Music]
just my throwing yeah hey man wait he
said you better not hit me in there fine
I'll be a good brother oh that sucked
how about one more
ready
now it says look look what I can do
Shawn
I knew that you could have taught you
well for you your masters do thank you
subscribe that still sounds nasty
you're not getting better I told you I'm
fine just a little beat well you need to
rest now
superhero yeah let's just fill up the
canteens before we head back that cough
has been going on for days Daniel I
really don't like that I told you I'm
fine
he's just been outside for a while are
you though are you though
we should fill these up now don't go out
during the night
here we go
the helitanker is on the Wildfire zone
get ready for water extraction Ranger
Diaz lazy Ranger nice work nice work
Daniel glad to see your training
sessions are paying off thanks to you so
glad I don't have to touch that water
it's too [ __ ] told hey what's your
mouse sorry
yeah I said [ __ ] yeah yeah dude watch
it what is your mouth okay what's your
language young man what what did you
find true
whoo Frank oh come on right
look Daniel crying I think I saw that
rabbit from the other day it's trying to
get home oh I want to see the bunny my
hand oh dude your face John you suck
come on Daniel I was just kidding around
[ __ ] Sean huh a family that lived here
what did happen I'm gonna say dead maybe
yeah mister moved out maybe do another
state but they left all their stuff
behind I don't know man
damn that kid is touchy I don't know man
maybe they live in Florida and only come
here every 10 years
maybe they got tired of these woods I
kind of like it here it's way cooler
than that crappy town where the shelter
was I just I miss my friends and my room
some I don't know if I could got an
animal anyway yeah me too I keep
interrupting their conversation sorry a
family who owned that cabin really seem
to enjoy themselves here I never caught
that can we go for our try new ride yeah
yeah sure
like you ain't sick enough yet what
about a water fight after that winners
lame this place must be cooling in
summer oh I'm tired this is cool snowman
it's Mike Wazowski I'm getting hungry
look at this no man you eat like a bear
but you don't gain any weight she does I
worked it off oh I almost forgot to
check our traps today you didn't say
anything about this huh Danielle's
definition of a cool snowman
it is cool I like
where are you what are you doing
finding that house was a miracle but I'm
afraid we can't stay here much longer
I can't really name Birds right probably
the name of a child who used to live
here
cool I miss dad's barbecues its marinade
with the achiote paste jalapenos
oh my god no guys Ducks are not my
freakin I'm not playing anything with
ducks on Meister I trained Daniel Daniel
can train for the dog wait
well I just pressed it and nothing
happened why is it cuz he's not around
me gain I was getting cold
let's get inside didn't warming wrongly
dogs sure tinium house we slice wood and
holding the logs with his power
pretty useful wildlife one Daniel cereal
too bad this wood is rotting you had to
cut some more to keep the house warm hey
there you are
yeah none of the trap sir no me tonight
nah me tonight
what kind of dog were you Sammy a cool
stream out like our little mushroom how
old are these kids today
runaway Millennials the part-time forest
squatters at your service
she loves it damn look getting any
better
it's medicine rely sorry guys we don't
take anymore guests inside did they
write that then I guess maybe okay let's
go yeah not my kind of weeds it's so
silent out here Oh neighbors no roads
it's like we're on another planet a new
planet that's exactly what we need
oh don't worry we'll make a fire we're
pros now dude
that cuff doesn't sound too good I'm
okay
just told you kicked ass today
level up I did that was so cool it's
getting easier every day
don't break the China this is a hotter
more like oh it's time to go are the
rules I told you about showing off
I was just whatever dude rules let's
find out what's the first one
[Music]
hide your power if you spend one plate
in a diner what happens people freak out
and when people freak what do they do
they call the tops exactly the second
rule is don't uh never talk about it
Wow nice Daniel cuz that's usually the
hardest rule for you shut off and the
final rule I know
come on um you can do it okay um avoid
danger run from danger this is the most
important one you know why uh I don't
know I mean with my power I can help us
uh whoa I mean as a last resort hello I
know that if there's any other way of
helping do that first
maybe if I used it before dad
no it still oh no no no be here no it's
not your phone there's no one's fault
out of Daniel you didn't even know that
[ __ ] was out of your control
but look what happened to the policeman
maybe this power is a curse or something
hey we have no clue would happen and
it's not your fault
don't worry mushroom I'm okay good puppy
she must be hungry what about you I'm
always hungry let's grow back I'll make
us some dinner
we've got to eat before she eats us what
the puppy okay oh we have a picture of
dad kind of weird to use stranger stuff
everyday but not like we have a choice I
hate it when I hear Daniel crying at
night I can't do [ __ ] mega robot ready
for takeoff three two
feels weird to be living in their own
well it's probably just a guy holding
him right I wish I helped dad more with
the house drawers back then poor guy I
guess kids have to grow up anyway right
hello to you little girl in Miami yeah
there is a Sun here and it burns I love
it
Tom knows everybody and I keep waiting
to meet Scarface we're at his friends
killer condo with a beach view and
balcony
the first has spoiled but I know John is
that a castle in the Alps so I don't
feel bad plus I really like it here
what a great way to start the new
century I miss our vacation at the
secret Lodge but I don't miss the
raccoons in my room hope you can come
visit soon after the summer love you
Maggie cute so the dad was living here
Oh
pretty disgusting but helps staying warm
yep we scored with these clothes plus
five street cred okay we have $10 we
have a sleeping mask what it's like cold
like a sleeping mask yeah uh blindfold
mask thing oh yeah that dudes number
what's this pocket knife that's use
vomits patrons
holy [ __ ] craziest oh yeah this is about
what happened last time what happened
after an earthquake yeah no no I'm not
quite I forgot he just his sketches
feeling safe for the first time since
Seattle thanks to Brody he did his
little sketch there already got us a
room he has a boss even less has some
cash real beds almost too comfy to be
true I miss you so much maybe you could
come back oh yeah cuz he phoned his
friend or his friend found him that's
called Lila one last time I missed her
laughing hope she won't get in trouble
now
phone went out for a midnight swim yeah
chucked his phone across the side wait
they'll love us
oh okay my second monitor just decided
to turn off hold up
okay it's interesting you're gonna turn
back home for me
hello oh no this is not good we can't
see anything
oh come on why why oh god sorry guys my
seconds wanted to it's just turned off I
don't know
sometimes it does this and it doesn't a
DVID mode
technical difficulties no and the only
way to do it is to follow reset my
computer and everything great
[Music]
yes
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I'm just trying one more time to turn it
on and off I didn't think it's gonna
work
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
please wait
No
okay
there you go I'm having to exit now um
oh I can't be bothered I'm gonna have to
like restart my computer and stuff uh
yeah this is all the fail of a
livestream so I'm just gonna go and
pretend that this never happens I'm
actually gonna go um I'll just play
again at some other point I'll just stop
for the beginning again
because I can't be bothered to reset the
whole compute engine just friend dances
so annoying
sorry about that but oh well I'll just
have a chill one I might play again
tomorrow if not then oh do it sometime
during the week cuz I mean life is
strange is life is strange life is
strange is a chill game anyway so should
be able to do it to me what have I got
to do tomorrow I'm going to the studio
it is my singing stuff do this yeah
doing some more singing and stuff and
now I need to plan Ross up to the EP I
might do some more video editing for the
music video the sweater music video we
should be geared OB we will know what
what do you mean Nikki ob we will know
calm down girl well you're not here when
I told you about my too much coffee
today there oh well I might just sing
you a little song for again what songs
do you like to sing check out my musical
me playlist and you'll find out and the
EP comes out in May oh yeah I need to do
the I need to do like a little hype
poster thing about the release of the EP
[Music]
[Music]
this is just a story of a girl he
thought her had she needed to forget in
a fresh time be careful what you say
your she no longer feels the same look
at her eyes see the stains my loved one
sorry
Oh soda for iWatch to retain the time
she lost
Wednesday is pardon like seconds since
both your paths crossed soda for a
sweater keeping out this cup weather
buddy he'd keeps her warm but it lasts
forever
she likes to think she is clever soda
for uh Nichols on your earth when you're
so fickle and it over her heart felted
heavy and brittle sorta for a key to
regain her dignity stowed all in a box
and by yours truly
[Music]
this is just a story of a girl he Sutter
hot now she's forgotten she's got a
fresh start
be careful what you say cause she no
longer feels the same look at her eyes
see the stains were the ones we love
can't you see that shoe can't even
breathe it sees my pee try but your body
oh well played I love why did you choose
you solid you could offer your ties with
you left's won rules love as you fade I
have to say
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
away
was this now worth the wait
it's just a story of a girl who saw
their hot
now she's forgotten she's got a friend
[Music]
that will be on the EP ep hype EP hype
this is even better than life history
well thanks at least I'm doing something
right today
stupid stupid stupid I hate over my
freaking second monitor does this I need
better screens in my life I need a
better screen British not talented for
music interesting interesting
okay why use exchange for the flirting
my face my blood my spell them through
means recycle
[Music]
[Music]
Tyler washes Bryl
we pursue my skin might not artificial
but it makes me the superficial mask I'm
addicted by
[Music]
the motions oh please stray the magic
Eagles the actions of our lives and
freedom comes with a choice we've chosen
to make me
[Music]
[Applause]
Hey
[Music]
robot that's not gonna be on the EP but
if all goes well I might make more it's
all we shall see we shall see I wish you
could have heard my drumming to that
song
drumming that'd be cool that'd be cool
probably we're kind of running it in the
ground even though it's funny I don't
know what you're talking about
hope 200 Sol's will be gone apparently
yes because I'm ginger that makes sense
hmm okay I'm sorry about this but I hope
you enjoyed it anyways um I will play it
soon are you planning on doing any shows
or at all once the EPS release I was
freakin loved at all um so I'm really
scared of like live shows but I've got I
do have a live show actually I should
probably like tell people more and it's
on the 4th of main may the force be with
you in Farnham
I think I'm not sure but yeah I should
probably like say more stuff about it
I'm just really nervous about playing
live but if that goes well that I'll
probably do some more I'm trying to get
my producer involved as well so he can
play the guitar I'd feel a lot less
scared if I was sawing up onstage with
me
so we'll see we'll see how it goes but
yeah I probably should do oh and I do
have an idea so for the release of the
EP I want to do a livestream gig so
it'll be like all life's tuned and you
guys can watch it and I'll be live and
should be fun I'm going to see my
producer tomorrow so hopefully we'll get
some time to to like test it out test
out his internet connection if that
could actually work at the studio
because I would be super cool like a
live stream from the studio that would
be super cool yeah I know you keep
wanting me to contact these stage people
I'm just really scared
I don't know cuz I don't know if I'm
ready and I feel like a festival is for
like people who play alive a lot I don't
I mean I guess I could just show them my
stuff and then they can decide for
themselves whether I'm good or not and
you're playing live now it's different
I'm not if you think about this
logically where am I in my bedroom it's
the same as just singing to yourself in
your room when you're actually live and
you can see people it's totally
different you know and there's a
microphone in front of you and you're
all miked up and hooked up it's
completely different to doing this but
I'm glad that you guys like it anyway
and you know support me I appreciate
that
[Music]
anyway I'm gonna go now sorry again this
is a weird date but hopefully you
enjoyed anyway okay I'm gonna go now I'm
actually gonna get right um goodbye
Edward buy some of them goodbye Ross
well goodbye Terry the time time what a
name
goodbye different level
you're very good dude thank you I
appreciate that I'm in such a weird mood
tonight I think it's just a coffee I
feel like really shaky oh I might play
some apex I've got work to do okay I'll
do some work and then I'll eat in there
and my baby pics so are you all on my
discord join my discord if you're not on
my discord already during my discord
please if you want to you don't have to
goodbye Edward kids off your show you're
going to stay amazing thank you thank
you yeah I find it so much easier to do
a show as well when my friends are there
and Jesus says
a little wine no I don't drink before I
sing on stage because I've done it
before I've had like a pint before
straight going on stage it's so I wait
to drink it after the show
it's me dan what why did you apologize
um I'm confused
encore encore hope to see you live
someday oh you guys miss me
oh we so it would be so fun to tour is
so fun to tour wait [ __ ] I know who
sorry I'm just swearing I know who
different level is now I'm gonna be in
one of his videos in in May hopefully
hopefully it's doing an interview why I
need to be using a documentary on indie
game development and indie games in
general but uk-based
indie games so it's quite interesting
just a little cup what just a little cup
wait from what cups Oh white wine no
wine goes right to my head even just
even just a little cup would go right to
my head I don't drink wine I'm not ready
a wine drinker so right so I know you
love the dark stuff I just don't want to
be known for that and it's so
embarrassing
I prefer much prefer the balls talk more
balls last dark very happy about that
anyway um different it was like I've
done from the other day I know I
remember now I remember now
for in France's new to go on stage with
or I could sit with you oh yeah I don't
ever bring my friends on stage you me
that'd be fun night I mean they
can't play anything but they could like
dance but now I just like so one of my
friends Nino especially is so good to
have in the crowd because she's just so
vocal and if I mess up or anything
she'll just scream over my mess up so it
just makes me feel so much less stress
and just like fun yeah smiles all of her
secrets in the documentary all of my
secrets so many secrets you have to play
music more often in live streams yeah I
should do I should do
I'm usually playing a bit too late so I
don't wanna wake up my my landlady but
it was early at this time so anyway I'm
gonna go now so thank you again for
watching and have a lovely day or
evening